وقال مفوض الازمات والطوارئ في الاتحاد
الاوروبي
ان النظام السوري قدم طلبا للمساعده وان
الطلب حول الى دول الاعضاء واضافها ينزع
ان الاتحاد سيرفع من مستوى الدعم المالي
المقدم للمنظمات الانسانيه في المناطق
المتضرره في شمال سوريا
الاتحاد الاوروبي يمول ويدعم شركائنا من
المنظمات الانسانيه في سوريا منذ اكثر من
عشر سنوات الوضع الانساني هناك سيء بالفعل
والزلزال زاد من فدحه الوضع نرفع مستوى
جهودنا من خلال هذه المنظمات وجهنا جزءا
من انشطتها تجاه هذا الامر نرفع من مستوى
الدعم المالي كذلك للمناطق المتضرره
تلقينا هذا الصباح طلبا من النظام السوري
للمساعده من خلال اليه الطوارئ وشاركنا
ذلك مع الدول الاعضاء ونشجعها على
المساعده